Another way of assessing personality is by sitting down with an individual one
on one and answering a series of questions. And these can be about how a person
behaves differently across different situations. They may ask what the person
was like when they were younger, or how they typically feel on any given day.
Now, usually this is quite comfortable and relaxing for the participant because
the questions are not limited to true or false, or agree or disagree type
questions. However, we still have a problem with who is going to rate the
answers? And whether or not those are reliable and valid. Now this technique is
very popular with psychotherapists. Who want to better understand their client
and their client's personality. Therefore, they may ask questions such as have
you always been anxious or in what situations do you find yourself most
anxious. But now let's go to Lauren and we're going to discuss projective
tests.